hi there steve kaufman here
now we're going to continue this series
in my
language learning faqs
that deals with the issue of
case endings verb endings conjugations
declensions which cause all kinds of
trouble
in the first uh video i said that the
concepts
um the general concept i think are
fairly straightforward the detailed
explanations of the various different
situations when we use this or that case
or tense are very difficult to
understand until we've had a lot of
exposure to the language
in the second video i pointed out how i
personally found it very difficult to
study the tables
that i made different attempts to do so
and i was unsuccessful i i felt it had
some impact but i'm not sure that the
time expended on that was was worth it
but maybe it's something that we need to
do occasionally to review the tables but
now i want to talk about what i think is
finally enabling me to make some
progress
in in what is a very difficult task
because we're used to in english saying
uh you know with my pen or
uh you know
you know apostrophe s for possessive and
so forth and then we come to another
system where they do things quite
differently and
you have to remember that the brain
wants to go down familiar pathways uh
perfect example in russian is
means for
but in my brain it seems to identify
with the la in french it does that you
know and so your brain will head down
familiar pathways when it comes across
things and you have to train it
to to react differently to accept these
different patterns as normal so we're
dealing with patterns we're dealing with
patterns of the language which
eventually have to become patterns in
the brain so what i do is
i do a lot of in link i say phrases i
save words and i tag them by dative
instrumental and so forth and then i
review these as examples of the of
instrumental and so forth and i get a
few wrong when i tag them and then i
think about them
maybe this is wrong and so the odd wrong
tag
is not a big deal because eventually
you'll have fewer mistakes
when i read if i'm not on link not on my
computer i'm constantly underlining and
highlighting different phrases examples
of the genitive the dative the
instrumental or different cases or verb
aspects and we should do the same if
we're learning a romance language and we
see a subjunctive underline it underline
it underlining then go back read that
chapter again and look at the stuff that
you underlined or if you're in link and
you tag it then you get to see a bunch
of examples of
the subjunctive or the genitive case or
whatever it might be so this is one way
while i'm exposing myself to a lot of
content and and similarly when i listen
and i hear a case and i recognize that
that's that case and i make a mental
note as i'm listening just that these
are examples of these patterns in
russian and that helps to
cause the neurons to fire because we
want to create
constant you know
firing between neurons to create these
new connections
another thing you can do which i i found
this book in russia when i was just
there
uh and this is a book that has 53
patterns 53 very common patterns in
russian with many many examples minimal
amount of explanation lots of examples
and i have enough experience with
russian now that i understand
you know that this is what happens in
the language but then i see a
concentrated dosage of examples of these
patterns so this is also a very good way
to review the most common patterns
because the patterns are not
you know
unlimited in number there is a finite
number
and so you can review this
you know i've gone through this book a
few times which is similar to what i do
in link where i
tag
uh certain patterns so
to summarize them by doing a lot of
reading and listening where i am paying
attention to the patterns
case endings cases
usage patterns
uh underlining them listening paying
attention when i listen to these
specific examples
reviewing them in these tagged lists
that i have
or getting a book like this which has a
lot of patterns minimal explanation the
explanation takes you away from the
pattern to my mind it's indirect kind of
explaining stuff that you kind of have
understand
i'm saying you shouldn't i'm not saying
you shouldn't do it but i would rely far
more on constant review of these
patterns
in order to create these new patterns in
your brain so that you start to do
things naturally so there you have it
that's my take on the whole issue of
learning
you know verb endings noun endings
adjective endings and so forth and so on
i hope that this was helpful thank you
for listening and send me more questions